a rocket has hit a house in a
neighborhood northwest of kabul's
airport the strike has been confirmed by
kabul's police chief he also said a
child died in the explosion meanwhile
the u.s military has confirmed that the
u.s carried out a drone strike in kabul
targeting multiple suicide bombers
intent on attacking the airport it's not
yet clear whether these are two separate
incidents
straight to kabul now where i am now
joined by journalist franz marty friends
what more can you tell us about uh this
latest explosion
as far as i'm aware there has been like
one explosion um different accounts say
that it was either a house or a moving
car
allegedly targeting members of the
self-declared islamic state that were
set to have planned another attack
a member of this group on uh
on the telegram chat
uh told the source of mine that a house
has been hit so it seems to be confirmed
by members of the group themselves who
exactly was hit um is unclear though
friends just how tense is the situation
right now
i mean that there are like threats that
has been for for days like this
uh it should be noted that for for combo
is not something like completely new
before um there were there were frequent
explosions
or like terror plots in kabul so this is
like no this doesn't come out of the
blue um what has changed is now that uh
yeah a drone strike inside the city of
kabul against such attackers would be
something new um a retired cia officer
tweeted about this that this might also
be an indication that the collaboration
with the taliban doesn't work that well
because otherwise they would rather have
like tried to arrest
the targets and also interrogate them
so it's it's more of a lost resort
that's the americans now pull out that
they earlier would probably have like
notified government forces
we understand that the us and the
taliban have been sharing intelligence
in order to prevent another terrorist
attack
how does this cooperation work as far as
your reporting is telling you
how exactly it works uh wasn't disclosed
by either side what u.s officials did
this close was that they share some
intelligence sanitized intelligence so
um redacted
uh one two taliban checkpoints to look
out for certain
patterns or certain threats so that they
can like prevent uh whatever
attack others might plan
to
yeah to reach the airport um us
officials said that they don't hand out
like specific lists names or so from
people that are cleared or not cleared
so they they try to make sure that the
taliban don't
learn too much but enough to be able to
hold up threats at checkpoints
journalist friends marty in kabul as
always franz many thanks
the last british military flight has
left the afghan capital kabul the united
kingdom says its mission is complete
after evacuating fifteen thousand people
in recent weeks the us is also
withdrawing its troops and is warning
people to stay away from kabul airport
due to intelligence reports of another
possible terror attack after last week's
suicide bombing time is running out for
afghans who still want to leave with the
u.s due to end its operations by tuesday
i'd like to welcome lucas vena he works
for an ngo that supports afghan staff
who assisted the german armed forces in
the country greetings lucas you're in
touch with people who are on the german
foreign office's departure list but
haven't made it on board of one of the
evacuation flights what are they telling
you
currently uncertainty is pretty good
just which describes best their emotions
uncertain about whether
they will be able to leave the country
the taliban
strengthens their power and will take
more and more control of authorities and
it's unclear whether they will still
give out passports to our local staff
which some sometimes still doesn't have
a passport yet and another question is
how will they cross borders to
neighboring countries without visas for
instance to pakistan iran without having
passports so there's a lot of
uncertainty for our local staff
german foreign minister heiko maas has
promised aid for countries bordering
afghanistan and he's starting his trip
to these countries today will money be
enough
it's a it's a good question well um we
might even have to to open our wallets
um met our ngo to to get some people out
we are still working on some of the
procedures for for that we are in touch
with the german federal foreign office
about our procedures we are working
closely together with them and
we hope to to find some solutions during
the next days
you must be worried about your
colleagues back in kabul
what can reasonably be done right now to
protect them
well not much
we are telling them to to stay out and
then in their hideouts
to really
protect themselves
we know some of them have
already left kabul back to hometowns um
back to family members of them
um we actually currently don't know any
of our local staff still being at kabul
international airport so
most of them have actually left this
area
but are now in hideouts and we are just
staying in touch with them daily uh i
mean pretty much every hour we we get
messages in and um they are asking what
should they should what should we do
what should we do and we can just say
well be patient we try to find solutions
well best of luck to you that's uh lucas
vayner with the sponsorship network for
afghan staff of the german armed forces
again many thanks
thank you